je reviens du marché regardé et j'ai
acheté des piments il faut dire que
j'avais l'embarras du choix il en existe
plus de 1000 variétés certains ont des
notes secret presque caramélisées
d'autres sont plus fruité aux plus fumer
certains ont même des nuances d'herbes
aromatiques
bref le piment y en a pour toutes les
sauces et tous les goûts en revanche ils
ont un point commun
cherchez bien allez vous brûlez ah bah
c'est ça justement ils brûlent aller
dans l'atelier on va faire le point sur
ce sujet brûlant
[Musique]
allumez le feu le piment est originaire
d'amérique latine
il était déjà utilisé dans de nombreux
plats lorsque christophe colomb l'a
découvert au cours de son premier voyage
à cuba en 1492
à l'époque il aromatisés même le
chocolat des mayas et des aztèques
vous imaginez aromatisés le chocolat
donc pic alors les conquistadors
espagnols ont ensuite ramené en europe
où il a tout de suite remporté un succès
fou des 1526 on le cultive dans toute
l'espagne d'où il se répand sur toute la
planète
bien sûr chacun elle a un peu arrangé à
sa sauce en france les choses se sont
passées plus lentement
le piment est arrivé d'espagne via le
pays basque et le languedoc au xviie
siècle en passant notamment par le
village d'espelette
d'où le piment d'espelette juste or mais
ce n'est qu'au xxème siècle lorsque les
cuisines exotiques chinoise vietnamienne
ou indiennes sont devenus à la mode que
le piment a vraiment explosé et dans
certaines recettes
il faut bien le dire c'est une véritable
explosion de saveurs pour nos papilles
sur mon en cuisine je vous explique
pourquoi cette sensation de brûlure est
provoquée par la capsaïcine un composé
chimique de la même famille que la
nicotine et la caféine qu'on le retrouve
dans la chair du piment quand on croque
dans un pee mort est la capsaïcine se
lie avec des récepteurs qui se trouve
sur la langue et qu'on appelle des no 6
septembre le problème c'est que ces
récepteurs sont les mêmes que ceux qui
réagissent à la chaleur du coup le
cerveau reçoit le même signal que
lorsque l'on a quelque chose de chaud
sur la l'orgue
chaud devant chaud d'où cette sensation
de chaleur voire de brûlures quand on
croque un piment mais je vous rassure il
ne s'agit bien que d'une sensation aucun
risque de se brûler la langue réellement
avec un piment la preuve
la baule
et pourtant 37,5 la température reste
bien la même ça prouve vraiment en fait
la présence de cette molécule de
capsaïcine dans le piment est un
mécanisme de défense une façon de
dissuader les prédateurs trop gourmand
et oui les animaux n'aime pas manger
trop épicé nous non plus d'ailleurs
en 2018 en voulant relever un défi un
américain de 34 ans a fini à l'hôpital
après avoir mangé un carolina reaper à
piment parmi les plus forts du monde bon
moi je vais plutôt me faire des pâtes
c'est dur bedous pas la peine de temples
à mais certains aliments sont très doux
le poivron ou le paprika par exemple
pour le savoir il suffit de consulter ce
que l'on appelle et l'échelle de
scoville elle mesure en unités scoville
la concentration en capsaïcine et donc
la force du piment un peu comme
l'échelle de richter a été utilisé pour
mesurer l'intensité des tremblements de
terre
son créateur l'américain wilbert coville
a eu l'idée de faire goûter une purée de
piments frais à 5 personnes et de
compter le nombre de dilution dans de
l'eau sucrée pour que ces cinq cobayes
n'ai plus aucune sensation de brûlure le
poivron qui fait partie de la famille
des piments mais qui ne contient pas du
tout de capsaïcine est tout en bas de
l'échelle à 0 le piment d'espelette
le chiffre qu entre 1500 et 2500 unités
scoville le piment de cayenne un peu
plus qu'autour doit être dilué entre 30
et 50 mille fois alors que le piment
peppers x désigné comme le plus fort du
monde en 2017 est à 3 millions de
dilution soit 180 mille unités scoville
renversant je suis sûr qu'une question
vous brûle encore les lèvres que faire
pour soulager cette sensation de bouche
en feu de l'eau de l'eau je vais plutôt
de commander un verre de lait 1
gadonneix patron
enfin patronne merci un verre d'eau même
glace et n'être pas au contraire l'eau
ne fait que disperser la capsaïcine dans
la bouche
la capsaïcine n'est pas hydrosolubles
elle est liposoluble elle ne se dissout
pas dans l'eau mais dans un corps gras
lorsque l'on mange un plat un peu trop
pimentée il vaut donc mieux boire un
verre de lait entier pour calmer le feu
dans la bouche ou bien manger un yaourt
entier qui contient du gras ou alors
avalé une cuillerée d'huile d'olive
aller raconter moi vos expériences en
commentaire de cette vidéo ça mettre un
peu de piment dans ma vie à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands en
voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Applaudissements]